hey youtubers is charlie so Game of
Thrones just confirmed that the title of
episode 3 is going to be both breaker so
I wanted to use that to lead off my Q&A
today but I've also got some news about
what's going to be happening next week
that I'll talk about at the end of the
video so here we go I should also say
just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far we'll
be talking about a little bit of season
6 stuff but it's all been publicly and
now so technically not spoilers here we
go first question leading it off Lucas
asks Jamie's in the Riverlands with
Brienne I think he's going to kill the
phrase with Brienne and blackfish Tully
well you have to remember that the
Tully's are on the opposite side of this
from the phrase so if they're going to
kill one in the title of the episode is
going to be both breaker then they
probably wouldn't kill the other really
what I think is going on here and you
probably guess from the backdrop on my
computer here is that Brienne is gonna
have her oath breaker moment her
Kingslayer moment that Jamie had not
only is the name of her sword oathkeeper
one of Jamie's many nicknames is also
Oathbreaker so it seems like there's
going to be a lot of Riverlands Jamie
Brienne stuff happening in episode 3 but
Oathbreaker that that episode title
applies to all of the storylines so
you're talking about donairs you're
talking about the stuff up at the wall
that to me is also really interesting
we'll have to talk about that when the
episode actually drops but one of the
most fun things to do before episodes
air is when you hear a tattoo like
Oathbreaker like what would that mean
for Jon Snow's character or like what
would that mean for Tyrians character so
just remember that when you're thinking
about what episode titles mean next
question p tasks talking about the
shorter game of thrones seasons wouldn't
this mean that the wall would have to
come down at the end of season 6 that's
definitely one of those things that I
would be very surprised by like oh my
god I can't believe they did it this
fast but it's totally possible I think
it really just depends on how fast is
denise's story line moves because I do
think the wall will come down before
Daenerys comes to Westeros with our army
like the wall will come down and
everyone will be like oh [ __ ] we're
totally screwed than in the 11th hour
dinner shall write in somehow I can't
wait for the scene where Daenerys tries
to load all of those Dothraki in their
horses onto ships to sail to Westeros
they got they have to get there somehow
next question Gordon asks expert
negotiating tactic by Dan and Dave or
just publicity the timing around this
premiere is a little too convenient
you're talking about them you know maybe
they're announcing
shorter seasons to try and create some
hype or try to bargain with HBO I don't
really think that's what's going on from
what I know about Dan and Dave
personally they don't really engage in
shenanigans like that like there's
always bargaining that goes on behind
the scenes I don't think they would
hijack a show in such a public way just
to try and get more money or get fans
more excited like they wouldn't troll
people that much they do enjoy small
jokes like David Benioff a couple of
seasons ago were this funny r + l equals
polo shirt but I think that's as far as
they would take it in terms of winking
from behind the camera next question
gilmer asks they could do some kind of
huge movie later on that goes to the big
screen well the part of the problem with
that is that HBO makes its money from
subscriptions and it would depend on how
much money they thought they could make
from a theatrical release I think it'd
be more likely that they would just do
the final episodes as if it were like a
giant big movie broken into a couple
pieces and then they would air that
theatrically after it airs on TV right
now the broadcast industry seems to be
moving more towards a video on demand
model like a netflix model so i don't
think theatrical release would be there
big go tube and if you remember before
season 5 started they did air a couple
episodes theatrically I think they just
do another version of that next question
Loretta asks honestly waiting for the
starts to finally be reunited you you
and everybody else cannot wait to see
some stars get together on screen I
think there'll be at least one reunion
this season if there's any hold out this
season I think it's going to be Arya
just because she's got so much of that
training montage that we see in the
trailers I think a lot of her scenes
going to be consumed with that making
the most of that second chance getting
her eyesight back but just remember the
title of that third episode Oathbreaker
even though i don't think that aria is
going to break her oath in the third
episode I don't think she's going to be
stuck in Bravos for the rest of the
series next question aesthetic asks
which character's story do you like the
most Jon Snow for me while say it
changes from season to season I was
actually expecting dark stands out last
season so now that we're getting that
I'm expecting her to be my favorite
character this year brian is another one
of my really favorite characters that
originally I didn't really care that
much about like when I first read the
books it was between 2008 in 2011 before
the show ever started but then
gwendoline christie came along and i was
like oh my god this is so compelling
she's so amazing so it does change over
time there'll be characters that I
probably didn't care about a couple
years ago that I might totally love
after the series is done
depending on how their stories play out
that's actually good question for you
guys let me know was there character
that you didn't really care about before
the TV show started that the TV show
like doubled down on and you're now
totally in love with next question Jason
asks first time writing here's this
picture of what looks like the four
horsemen leaders on the White Walkers
here I'll actually put the picture up
right now the one on the right looks
like the white Walker Jon Snow killed
last season with Longclaw at hardhome
did anyone else notice this well if you
remember the white Walker that he killed
was basically shattered into a thousand
pieces so in the literal sense it's not
the same white Walker I think that the
makeup and the actor just looks very
similar as far as we know all of the
White Walkers with the exception of the
night's king maybe are those male
children that Craster laid out in the
woods as sacrifices so you're basically
looking at the sons of Craster who have
been raised and turned into white
walkers but there's still so much about
their mythology that we don't know so I
think a lot of winds of winter is going
to spell that out a little bit better
next question Shelby asks not sure if
anyone else noticed but the men in the
scene looked like the red wedding
actually I put the picture up here again
or all in Lannister armor definitely
looks like the same Hall of the twins
may have some revenge on the phrase this
season so there are a couple big Frey
related events in dance with dragons and
winds of winter if you've ever heard the
phrase free pies that also plays into
that it's not so much a red wedding type
of event but it is a revenge of sorts
against the phrase for the red wedding
in a really gruesome amazing way but it
involves a bunch of characters that I
don't know if the TV show is going to do
so they might be swapping a bunch of
things here what's that to wait and see
but don't worry there will be some sort
of payback for the red wedding in a
really spectacular way even if the show
changes it just a little bit just
remember the idea of a frape I so
excited about eating Freight pies but
thank you everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do so
here's the important stuff first episode
is going to drop next week if you don't
have it I'd recommend using HBO now if
that's not available to you just be sure
to check what options are available to
you based on which country you live in
HBO actually does a really good job of
dropping episodes all at the same time
around the world if you're watching on
TV sometimes there's like a couple hours
time delay because the time zones but
even if you have to wait a couple hours
to watch it it's only a couple hours
it's not like you have to wait weeks and
weeks to watch an episode
after everyone else if you new to my
channel and you don't really know how my
Game of Thrones videos work in the
season typically I do like a bonus video
on like a really specific topic you know
something from history then I'll do a
video for each of the episodes and then
I'll do like a Q&A video there's a
giveaway every week when I'll actually
say congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Ron Smith I'm sure I'm
butchering your name but you win a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel swing get your contact
details that's just on the about page
and what will happen with the giveaways
is that you know usually those will
start whenever I post like a bonus video
and they'll just stay open till I post
the Q&A video so I'm gonna try and do
three videos a week just like I did last
season if for some reason I get hit by a
bus and I'm not able to do that i'll
just be sure to let everybody know on
the channel as well as on social if you
don't know what my social links are
twitter is awesome emergency and
facebook is facebook.com / emergency
awesome you can follow me there for
updates i post a bunch of small edits
there too but as for this week i'm not
really expecting like a giant big
trailer to drop but i think the game of
thrones is going to be posting some more
EPK if there's anything really cool i'll
do a video for it but otherwise it'll
just be a normal bonus video so next
sunday [ __ ] gets real is going to be
awesome if you guys have no idea what's
going on with the shorter seasons you
can click here to learn all about that
we're still getting eight seasons likely
but they're just going to compress them
a little bit and you can click here for
the last big trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you